what we're going to do in this video is
talk about presidential signing
statements and these are statements that
presidents issue when they are signing a
bill into law they don't always do this
in fact it was quite infrequent for a
very long time the first signing
statement was issued by James Monroe but
it was quite infrequent until we get to
the modern times and starting with
Ronald Reagan they'd become much much
more common for presidents of both
parties and even though it is not
considered by legal scholars to be
legally binding so not legally binding
presidents still do it and they have
multiple reasons sometimes it acts as a
bit of an explainer for why they are
signing the law they might say how great
the law is why they think it's a good
idea but sometimes they also say what
problems there are in the law and in an
extreme case they can sometimes say that
there are parts of the law that are
unconstitutional and those parts that
are unconstitutional the executive
branch might not follow exactly the way
the law states well the obvious question
is if it's not legally binding why does
the president even take the trouble
well the explainer purpose might be
political or it might rally up the base
but issuing a statement on the problems
it's the president's way of signaling to
the entire executive branch and to
Congress that hey look don't be
surprised when I don't follow the letter
of the law of the parts that I think are
unconstitutional and to make this
tangible let's look at some actual
signing statements this is a signing
statement by President George W Bush in
2006 today I have signed into law
HR 972 the trafficking Victims
Protection reauthorization Act of 2005
this Act enhances our ability to combat
trafficking in persons by extending and
improving prosecutorial and diplomatic
tools and also adds new protections for
victims so that part's kind of an
explainer but then it goes on to say
section 104 purports to require the
Secretary of State prior to voting for a
new or reauthorized peacekeeping mission
under the US
pieces of a multilateral organization to
submit to the Congress a specific report
the executive branch shall construe this
reporting requirement in a manner
consistent with the president's
constitutional authority as
commander-in-chief and the president's
constitutional authority to conduct the
nation's Foreign Affairs and so what
they're saying is hey hold on a second
here Congress you want our Secretary of
State before making this decision to
submit a report every time you're kind
of starting to muck with how the
executive branch executes there so this
is signaling a bit to the Congress says
hey don't be surprised if we don't
follow this exactly the way that you are
expecting you have a similar tone in an
executive order from President Obama in
2009 today I have signed into law HR
11:05 the Omnibus appropriations act
2009 this bill completes the work of
last year by providing the funding
necessary for the smooth operation of
our nation's government so once again a
bit of an explainer but then it goes on
to say the Department of Justice has
advised that a small number of
provisions of the bill raise
constitutional concerns and then it goes
on to list actually several bullet
points and I'm just going to give you
one of them just so you get a sense of
things legislative aggrandizement
committee approval requirements so when
you aggrandize yourself it's making
yourself more than you really are and so
a legislative aggrandizement is the
legislative branch trying to go beyond
their legislative powers numerous
provisions of the legislation purport to
condition the authority of officers to
spend or reallocate funds on the
approval of congressional committees
these are impermissible forms of
legislative aggrandizement in the
execution of the laws other than by
enactment of statutes therefore although
my administration will notify the
relevant committees before taking the
specified actions and will accord the
recommendations of such committees
all appropriate and serious
consideration spending decisions shall
not be treated as dependent on the
approval of congressional committees so
here in this signing statement President
Obama saying look this is overstepping
the bounds of legislative authority to
tell us how we will spend these things
we'll take your advice under
consideration but dictating how to
execute is not the job of the
legislative branch so I'll leave you
there I encourage you to look up more
presidential signing statements they're
readily available on the Internet
they're part of the federal registry and
think about why presidents do this and
what role does this have and why this is
considered an informal power of the
President